الخدمة السرية هي أكثر من
نظارة شمسية سوداء وبدلات من قطعتين ،
إنها أيضًا فريق من النخبة من
المحققين الذين يحلون بعضًا من
أكبر جرائم الأمة في بعض الأحيان باستخدام
لا شيء أكثر من بقعة حبر هنا
نحن بهو الخدمة السرية.
الطلقات الوحيدة المصرح بها التي
يمكننا الحصول عليها في الطابق العلوي في المختبر ، حصلنا على
رؤية جميع محللي الآلات عالية التقنية التي
يستخدمها محللو الطب الشرعي لديهم
أسماء بأشياء مثل 8000 بعدهم
حتى تعرف أنها معقدة ، هل
صورت طابعة قمت بتصويرها  مختبر يشمل
أشخاصًا مثل تريستا المتخصص في
تحليل خط اليد للتحقيق في
رسائل التهديد أو مذكرات الفدية ،
يحقق جيفري في العناصر الاحتيالية
مثل بطاقات ائتمان الشيكات الخاصة بالمسافرين
وإيرينا تعمل في مكتبة International
Inc ، اسمي إيرينا جيمون ،
أنا محلل مستندات
مع الولايات المتحدة  Secret Service -
تحتوي الخدمة السرية على أكبر
مكتبة حبر في العالم ، حيث يوجد حاليًا أكثر من
12000 حبر في المجموعة
يتضمن هذا أقلام الحبر المعبأة في زجاجات
وخراطيش الطابعة بشكل أساسي يستخدم هذا الفريق
من العلماء الحبر للمساعدة في حل
الجرائم التي لا تعمل بقايا الحبر الخاصة بهم ، فلا تفعل
ذلك
جيدًا ، لذا إليك مثال يكتب شخصًا
رسالة تهديد إلى الرئيسة
إيرينا ستأخذ عينة من هذا الحبر ثم
تقارن  بالنسبة لمجموعتها بالضبط ،
يمكنها معرفة نوع الحبر الذي تم استخدامه
، ونأمل أن يساعد ذلك في حل الحالة ،
إليك عينة حبر أخرى لا تعطيني
هذا النص ، حيث أن
الأوراق النقدية الأكثر تزويرًا في الولايات المتحدة هي
20 دولارًا ويتم طباعتها بالحبر الذي تم فحصه
مما يعني وجود شخص ما  تأخذ أنها
بسيطة جدًا في الطابعة المنزلية وتقرر
طباعة النقود ، يمكن أن تقارن إيرينا
العملة المزيفة بأي طابعات
موجودة في مسرح الجريمة وتساعد في
جعل المطابقة جيدة.
صريحًا في الغالب
بالحبر الأسود والكثير من الأحبار
السوداء وهي سوداء فقط ، إنها في الواقع مجموعة
من مكونات الألوان المختلفة التي يمكن أن
تكون a  الأزرق والأحمر والأصفر ربما
القليل من اللون الأخضر يمكن لإرينا بسبب عدم
وجود تسلسل أفضل لتسلسل الحبر الأسود
مع الحمض النووي والعثور على الانهيار الدقيق
للون وهذه هي الطريقة التي يمكنها بها إجراء تطابق ،
لذا فإن ما يظهر باللون الأسود للوهلة الأولى
هو في الواقع  مختلف تمامًا
من الداخل ، ومن الممتع حقًا
أن أكون كيميائيًا قادرًا على تفكيك الحبر
ومعرفة كيف أصبح من
الغريب في قلبي ، فأنا أحب فرن الكيمياء ،
فأنا أحب لغز حل الحالة.
القيام بذلك قد
لا يبدو تمامًا كما هو على التلفزيون ، لكن
من الممتع حقًا أن تكون في مختبر وأن تكون
قادرًا على إجراء أي تحليل وأن تكون قادرًا
على مساعدة ومساعدة جميع
وكالات إنفاذ القانون التي أعمل
معها يوميًا حتى تتمكن إيرينا  أعطيتنا
المزيد من الأمثلة على أساس الحاجة إلى المعرفة
ولم تكن بحاجة إلى أن تعرف جيدًا
أنه يبدو أن هذه الحالة قد جفت تمامًا
[موسيقى]